if you believe we have crashed craft uh
stated earlier do we have the bodies of
the pilots biologics came with some of
these recoveries yeah
were they I guess human or non-human
biologics
non-human and that was the assessment of
people with direct knowledge on the
program I talked to that are currently
still on the program UAP are in our
airspace but they are grossly
underreported these sightings are not
rare or isolated they are routine
military air crew and commercial pilots
trained observers whose lives depend on
accurate identification are frequently
witnessing these phenomena has the u s
government become aware of actual
evidence of extraterrestrial otherwise
unexplained forms of intelligence and if
so when do you think this first occurred
I like to use the term non-human I don't
like to denote origin keeps the aperture
open both scientifically uh certainly
like I've discussed publicly uh
previously 1930s after upgrades were
made to our Jets radar systems we began
detecting unknown objects operating in
our airspace the the technology that we
faced was far superior than anything
that we had
and you could put that anywhere if you
if you had one you captured one you
reverse engineered it you got it to work
you're talking something can go into
space go someplace drop down in a matter
of seconds do whatever it wants and
leave
and there's nothing we can do about it
nothing